what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have a lot
of marvel news to break down we have an
update for thor love and thunder from
taika watiti which in turn gives us an
update for its trailer and it looks like
miss marvel might actually be coming out
before thor love and thunder both the
series and the trailer for it and to top
it all off we have some really awesome
blade and midnight sun's new so like i
said a lot to break down let's dive into
it but if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest marvel news now the first
thing that we need to do is watch what
taika with tt has recently said in a
recent interview thor
tell me everything there's nothing left
after i've said everything for the last
two years it's still not finished it's
not finished when is it gonna be
finished it comes out in july so
probably the end of june
like a day before the premiere that's
how we do it what's funny is and i
mentioned this in my last thor love and
thunder trailer update video is that
taikawatiti actually told me the same
thing at the eternals premiere and it
looks like it is still not done and it
looks like it's going to come down to
the wire thor love and thunder comes out
july 8th of this year and taika kind of
jokes but it also kind of doesn't seem
like he's joking at the same time and
says that it'll probably be done the end
of june which is obviously right before
july so this tells us that they actually
have quite a bit more work to do until
the movie is finalized now what does
this mean for the trailer well
unfortunately it's not that good of news
especially if you combine it with some
other recent rumors that we've heard and
i'll talk about just a bit but we're in
march right now and taika is saying that
the movie's probably going to be
finished late june that means they have
four months worth of work to do for this
film now i'm sure taika is exaggerating
a little bit obviously but the scale of
this movie is supposed to be pretty dang
big and i'm sure they are waiting on a
few scenes that they can throw in the
trailer to be finished you can't really
do a trailer unless the scenes that are
going to be in the trailer are finished
now it's just a teaser trailer and you
don't want to give too much away so i'm
sure there's some scenes that they could
put together to give us a good little
teaser but having said that they are
still probably waiting on a few more
scenes to be able to throw in there
because it still has to be a really good
teaser it just doesn't have to show us
everything so although it still might
come this month we might be waiting just
a little bit longer for it especially if
you consider the rumors that the next
trailer we're going to be getting is for
miss marvel now this is just kind of a
rumor going around this is not confirmed
in any way but rumor has it that's the
next trailer we're getting miss marvel
which obviously means thor love and
thunder isn't going to be coming anytime
soon if this rumor is true and again it
might not be but what's funny is that we
don't actually have a specific release
date yet for miss marvel we just know
that it's coming out this year now we
presume it's going to be coming out
after moon night but again we're not
really sure when it's going to come but
if we are indeed getting the trailer for
miss marvel next if that's the next
marvel trailer we're getting that means
we can kind of pinpoint a sort of vague
release date for miss marvel so thor
love and thunder comes out july 8th and
if the miss marvel trailer does come
beforehand we could probably assume that
the show is going to drop before thor
love and thunder comes out so before
july but at the same time moon knight is
about to debut at the end of this month
march 30th it's going to have six
episodes so it'll probably run until the
middle of may then we have doctor
strange and the multiverse madness and
then they might release miss marvel then
in june if this starts at the beginning
of june it's said to have six episodes
so it will end before thor love and
thunder comes out and this might be the
release schedule for marvel studios
right here and again this is not
confirmed but if the rumors are true
combined with what taikawatiti said
about finishing thor love and thunder
right before the premiere of the movie
then this might actually be what's going
to happen the next trailer will be miss
marvel and it will release some time
before thor love and thunder and again
regardless we shouldn't have to wait
that much longer for a thor love and
thunder trailer after all it is getting
pretty close and like i said they don't
need to finish the whole movie to give
us just a teaser and in some other
really awesome news it looks like blade
is going to be making his mcu debut
sooner than we thought i should say his
on-screen debut since we did hear his
voice in the post-credits scene of the
eternals talking to kit harington's
black knight dane whitman but the
supernatural side of marvel comics is
about to come to life in the mcu we are
starting off with moon knight and then
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness is going to really take us there
and not to mention one division really
actually is the one who started it off
introducing agatha harkness true witches
and the darkhold and the darkhold is
going to be making another appearance in
multiverse of madness and the darkhold
might actually be a key connector to
many different movies and shows for
example rumor has it that blade is going
to be coming to the mcu in a disney plus
show before his actual film speculated
to be werewolf by night and blade could
be recruiting people for a certain team
aka the midnight suns werewolf by night
is a halloween special that is coming to
disney plus that has yet to be confirmed
by disney but has been confirmed by many
reliable sources now obviously this is
going to come out during halloween time
since it's a halloween special now it is
important to note that werewolf by night
has been confirmed to be coming to the
mcu and this has been confirmed in the
moon knight trailer in the trailer we
see moon knight in full costume on top
of somebody beating the absolute crap
out of him if you look closely enough
you can tell that this person underneath
is werewolf by knight now moon knight
werewolf by knight and blade all have
connections to each other and they have
connections to the darkhold as well so
it makes sense that these shows will
start to introduce other supernatural
characters now according to the
cosmiccircus.com they believe that blade
is going to be appearing in werewolf by
night and the cosmiccircus.com does have
an interesting theory stating that blade
could actually be recruiting members for
a supernatural team and perhaps that's
what blade was doing talking to the
black knight at the end of the eternals
in the post-credits scene starting to
recruit it would also make sense that if
blade is indeed starting a supernatural
team that he would want moon knight to
be a part of that team as well and
doctor strange now bringing it back to
the darkhold the darkhold is actually
responsible for the creation and also
the destruction of vampires and
werewolves in the marvel comics universe
the darkhold will be explored more in
multiverse madness so they could make it
to where they explain how werewolf by
night actually comes about in the mcu we
will see him before in moon night so
we'll get a little bit of an
introduction then and then hopefully
multiverse of madness explains it
further and then we'll go into the
halloween special now blade and werewolf
by night kind of have the same enemy
blade's number one enemy is count
dracula i mean blade is a vampire hunter
and dracula is the vampire and
coincidentally dracula is responsible
for the werewolf curse falling upon jack
russell's family many many years ago so
they do share a big common enemy so
blade debuting in either moon night or
werewolf by night actually makes a lot
of sense especially if he is indeed
recruiting a supernatural team to take
down some big bad villain that could be
count dracula and this could actually be
the start of the formation of the
midnight suns again the supernatural
side was kicked off with one division
but moon knight is really going to step
it up a notch and then doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness is
supposed to be somewhat of a marvel
horror film and this is probably where
things are actually going to get out of
hand much like the doctor strange
variant says in this movie so let me
know how excited you are for the
introduction of blade to the mcu let me
know what you think about that trailer
for thor loving thunder what do you hope
we see in it keep in mind it is just a
teaser and how excited are you for the
possibility of the midnight sun's
supernatural group coming to the mcu let
me know your thoughts in the comments
down below don't forget to like this
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest marvel news for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram or twitter and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof